avec nous Sébastien McMahon stratège en
chef et gestionnaire de portefeuilles
chez
Ia groupe financier industriel alliance
et Clément Gignac économiste sénateurs
indépendant bonsoir messieurs et bonsoir
Clément Gignac d'abord qu'est-ce qui est
différent dans ce qu'on voit
présentement de 2008
et un peu bien penser qu'en 2008 c'est
aller pratique bancaires qui laissaient
désirer on avait fait des ce qu'on
appelle des hypothèques étudiotiques
c'est à dire des gens qui auraient pas
vraiment les moyens d'acheter une maison
et qui peut se procurer donc c'était les
pratiques bancaires à travers toutes les
ethnies peu importe des grosses banques
les petites banques qui faisaient défaut
cette fois-ci c'est plutôt les petites
banques régionales qui sont plus
concentrés dans le secteur région qui
font face à de la méfiance de la part
des déposants et cela ce qu'on a vu dans
ce qu'on avait et qui plus est le fait
que l'administration a changé des règles
de jeu pour que les petites bandes de
moins de 250 milliards aux États-Unis ne
soient pas soumis ou stress test a pu
faire en sorte qu'on peut afficher des
bons bénéfices mais le voilà quand il y
a une petite crise de confiance là à ce
moment-là on voit les impacts donc c'est
venu fragiliser en quelque sorte
davantage le système bancaire la semaine
passée il y a eu silver Gates c'était
davantage lié aux plateformes de crypto
monnaie on a c'est le cas aujourd'hui
signature on surveille la First Bank
également
Sébastien McMahon ses institutions
sont-elles entraînées par les mêmes
problèmes ben il y a des cas isolés
là-dedans je vous dirais silicone vers
les banques avaient sa clientèle qui
était particulière c'est une clientèle
qui est pour lequel le modèle d'affaires
elle est très bien quand les taux
d'intérêt était bas puis l'économie
allait très bien donc avec le
ralentissement économique qu'on a vu ce
matérialiser récemment que les taux
d'intérêt qui a augmenté les clients
avaient besoin d'argent la banque
pendant ce temps-là perdait sur ses
actifs comme il était décrites tantôt
donc ça c'est un cas isolé mais
maintenant on va le savoir est-ce que il
y a d'autres modèles d'affaires de
banque qui sont à risque parce que des
petites banques régionales comme ça du
côté américain il y en a 4550 il y en a
qui sont très locales il y en a qu'un
modèle d'affaires qui est très
spécifique il y en a des il y en a
beaucoup qui sont vulnérables vous
pensez ben il y en a d'autres
probablement qui sont vulnérables à
gauche et à droite maintenant est-ce
qu'on va voir d'autres d'autres insectes
sortir dans le dessous des roches c'est
une bonne question mais je vous dirais
que les prochaines semaines prochaines
jours risque d'être crit Clément de
votre côté vous vous rappelez bien sûr
de 2008 est-ce que d'autres banques à
votre avis pourraient tomber et si
d'autres banques tombent est-ce qu'un
effet de panique qui peut être engendré
mais on peut pas exclure que d'autres
banques pour admis sous-tellent parce
que dans le fond il y en a peut-être au
niveau de leur placement aussi que à la
réalité la Réserve fédérale a décidé de
mettre en tutelle mais le fait que
maintenant le président va être un et
Madame yeden ont décidé que toutes les
déposants faut juste ceux qui ont en
boîte de 150 000 dollars mais toutes les
déposants pourraient toucher leur argent
ça ramène une confiance selon moi la
différence qu'on a Géral avec 2008 aussi
c'est que le gouvernement américain ne
deviendra pas actionnaire des banques et
l'exécuter des banques est mis dehors si
vous êtes sous tutelle alors donc en
2008 c'était vraiment les contribuables
qui étaient finalement leur argent à
risque cette fois-ci on s'occupe des
clients des déposants mais clairement le
message pour les investisseurs les
actionnaires les dirigeants venez pas
cogner à la porte de washing Washington
parce que finalement ça dépend de votre
investissement et l'exécuter votre mis à
la porte vous pensez que Sébastien
McMahon qu'on a appris de 2008
aujourd'hui là le président Biden qui
sort rapidement et qui annonce qu'il a
annoncé ce matin ouais ouais on a appris
puis on sait qu'il faut agir rapidement
faut agir avec force c'est tout un
bazooka qui a été sorti hier pour aider
pour protéger les déposants maintenant
on est dans le monde la finance
comportementale on se demande est-ce que
c'est assez pour satisfaire la
perception des clients de ces banques là
je vous dirais que probablement
plusieurs clients n'oubliez pas en 2023
la confiance envers les institutions est
un petit peu plus faible qu'elle l'était
peut-être il y a 15-20 ans donc est-ce
que les clients vont se dire je suis en
confiance je laisse mon argent là on va
pas dire ben oui mais je prends mon
téléphone je fais des transferts de
fonds puis je vais aller plutôt
m'installer dans des plus grandes
banques donc cet effet là qui pourrait
faire boule de neige puis même si
l'argent est protégé il y a quand même
quelques banques qui pourraient avoir
affirmé à former boutique là au bout de
tout ça Clément génial qu'est-ce que les
grandes banques canadiennes le système
bancaires canadien est totalement à
l'abri de ce qui se passe mais en fait
faut garder l'esprit que le système
bancaire canadien est beaucoup mieux
capitalisé les banques sont beaucoup
plus diversifiées ils sont diversifiés à
travers le pays
diversifier à travers les secteurs
l'économie contrairement à Silicon
Valley qui était en Californie et
orienté plus vers les pompiers high tech
ou signature banque qui était plus
orientés vers les cryptos queencies donc
beaucoup mieux capitaliser et en plus
ils sont soumises à des stress tests ce
qui n'étaient pas le cas dans le cas de
signature banque ou dans le cas des
condolés que si les taux d'intérêt
augmentent beaucoup qu'elle arrive-t-il
à votre portefeuille or ça veut dire que
vous devriez augmenter votre capital
clairement il n'était pas semé ce stress
là aux États-Unis les banques en mode de
sens comme hier alors que toutes nos
banques canadiennes sont soumises donc
je suis très rassuré oui regardez des
titres à
de l'ordre de 11% alors qu'au Canada les
types de banque ont pas baissé tellement
un ou deux pour cent est-ce que ça
stoppe la possibilité encore de hausse
de taux d'intérêt aux États-Unis
Sébastien McMahon ben je pense que ça
met la barre très haute parce que la
Réserve fédérale comme les autres
banques centrales il y a un mandat de
plein emploi de contrôle d'inflation
mais aussi de stabilité financière puis
dans le dernier rapport de la fête
dernier rapport annuel qui couvrait
l'année 2021 il faisait état qu'en fin
d'année 2021 les banques étaient très
exposées au risque de taux d'intérêt
puis on sait qu'en fin 2022 c'est encore
pire donc comment est-ce qu'on jongle
avec d'un côté un système financier qui
est plus fragile puis de l'autre côté le
combat contre l'inflation s'enverrai un
drôle de message de faire une hausse de
50% la semaine prochaine même faire une
hausse la semaine prochaine peut-être ça
pourrait être mal perçu donc la fête
sera morte un peu entre l'arbre et
l'écorce en terminant Clément junior
qu'est-ce que c'est le début d'une crise
financière
non c'est une crise de confiance qui est
très très localisée le fait que les
autorités ont réagi rapidement et qui
grandissent à toutes les déposants leur
argent à 100% va faire en sorte que la
confiance va revenir cependant pour les
actionnaires et les investisseurs il y
aura dilution au niveau de l'équité
parce que les règles de jeu vont changer
les autorités réglementaires américaines
vont devenir beaucoup plus difficile et
exigeront plus de capital de la part des
banques et c'est pour donc vous refaire
une distinction entre les déposants qui
sont rassurés versus les investisseurs
qui eux pourraient voir leur action BC
et certainement le modèle d'affaires des
banques régionales va être affectées ça
va être plus difficile de faire des
profits pour eux intéressant au risque
de se reparler Sébastien McMahon merci
Clément Gignac merci un plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI